[Music]
hey there my name is Willow and I'm
going to show you how to learn what has
become my go-to pattern in poy juggling
poy jugglers call it the SN no beat
Cascade the joy of this Cascade is its
stability and its
variability so let's break it down
first let's address the ever necessary
how do you start any po juggling pattern
one PO is held in a thumb and index
finger and the second poy is held in the
pinky end of the hand now the first poy
that you throw is the pinky
side great now let's start with one poy
practice what poy jugglers call the no
beat toss spin the poy backward
once make the
toss then catch with the other hand
directly into the spin to repeat this is
the path of each po during this pattern
it's caught into a p spin tossed and
repeat the trick to a good noi toss is
pulling back slightly on the handle as
it leaves the hand minimizing the
rotation just let it slip out of your
fingers it's good to practice with one
toy while moving both
hands notice that they move up and down
at the same time in a steady Rhythm this
is what makes the pattern
synchronous one key to success with po
juggling is matching the height of your
throw with necessary movement underneath
in this case match the height and
rotation with the time it takes to make
a full swing with the other hand toss
spin toss spin toss
spin okay keep up the good work it's
time for two po now spin both POI at the
same time and toss one to start see how
it feels to toss and catch but keep one
beat as a rest between doing it
again toss toss catch catch catch rest
toss toss catch catch rest when that
feels comfortable get rid of the rest
count toss toss catch catch toss toss
catch
[Music]
catch you've mastered these steps the
third Poise should become very easy just
fit it in and keep doing what you're
doing
[Music]
you can vary this pattern in lots of fun
ways like tossing one and a half
rotations catching in
penguin or even doing reverse or anti-
spin
tosses try mixing it up when you feel
like
exploring thanks for watching and you're
welcome to message me with any questions
happy practicing